merci madame merkel de nous faire le
plaisir de venir aujourd'hui avec votre
vice chancelier administrateur de la
province france monsieur le vice
chancelier
j'aurais aimé pouvoir vous appeler
monsieur le président de la république
par respect pour votre fonction mais pas
plus que votre prédécesseur vous
n'exercez cette présidence à président
de la république ne pourrais pas dire le
souverainisme c'est le déclinisme comme
vous venez de le faire parce que le
président de la république est garant de
la constitution française et que le
titre 1 de la constitution française et
de la souveraineté
un président de la république ne peut
être ignorée avec constance les intérêts
de la france
la dre de la france n'est pas de se
soumettre aveuglément et une politique
décidée à berlin bruxelles ou à
washington son intérêt et votre devoir
c'est de défendre sa souveraineté
l'intéret de la france n'est pas de
donner ce spectacle affligeant d'une
france à la remorque de l'allemagne sur
la question migratoire
quand dans un geste parfaitement
irresponsable la chancelière merkel dit
qu'il faut accueillir 800 mille migrants
à bras ouverts vous applaudissez en
quelques jours plus tard elle suspend
schengen et veut maîtriser ses
frontières vous applaudissez encore
donnant de la france l'image désolante
d'un pays à la dérive
titubant sur une question pourtant si
essentielle à la sécurité à la
prospérité et à la défense de l'identité
de la france
l'intérêt de la france c'est aussi de ne
pas abdiquer face au docteur cheval
quand se décide la politique économique
du continent
alors même que cette politique est
synonyme de chômage massif de précarité
et d'effondrement de notre système de
protection sociale
c'est au contraire de résister et
d'empêcher la grèce
les autres pays du sud de l'europe puis
la france de s'engluer dans une spirale
osterrieth air sans fin dans le seul
objectif de sauver l'euro et le modèle
économique à
monde bas salaires vous venez tous deux
ici en séance de rattrapage car votre
union européenne est en train de
s'effondrer aggravant les assauts
migratoires comme les assauts économique
est obligé de se maintenir par le
chantage la menace et l'intimidation
votre modèle c'est la vassalisation aux
états unis l'austérité la concurrence
déloyale la surveillance massive des
citoyens
le dumping social la submersion
migratoire
je porte un autre modèle qui rassemble
aujourd'hui les peuples d'europe celui
de l'indépendance de l'europe des
nations dans un monde multipolaire du
protectionnisme intelligent et oui des
libertés individuelles de la défense de
la défense de notre sécurité et de nos
identités par l'arrêt total de
l'immigration de masse à certains résume
en disant que je suis lentilles merkel
j'en accepte l'auguré je ne vous je ne
vous reconnais pas en effet madame le
droit de disposer de nous dans une
tentative absurde d'une domination
allemande de l'europe la défense des
intérêts allemands ne justifie pas la
vassalisation des autres peuples
d'europe
je suis
je suis dans cet hémicycle la voie des
européens libre de nos peuples
souverains qui se détournent de l'union
européenne parce qu'ils ont soif de
nation je suis là représentants du
peuple français qui se détournent de
vous monsieur hollande comme il s'est
détourné hier de monsieur sarkozy parce
qu'il a soif de france bilingue
on ne peut pas